You can track exceptions and
crashes in Google Analytics.
So in the dashboard, you would go to
Behavior > Crashes and Exceptions.
And the exceptions are grouped
by the app version number.
You could drill down with
the different version numbers.
And see, I had a NoSuchMethodException
and a NumberFormatException.
So you can track caught exceptions and
uncaught exceptions.
So to track exceptions that get caught,
you need to send an exception hit.
And you use ExceptionBuilder to build
a hit, and you set the description and
you setFatal, whether or
not it's fatal, and that's boolean.
And then you build the hit and send it.
And for uncaught exceptions,
you can't add code,
obviously, because you don't know where
in the code the exceptions occur.
However, you can enable automatic
tracking for uncaught exceptions.
And to do this you set
ga_reportUncaughtExceptions
to true in the tracker config file.
I just want to mention that there have
been some issues about sending hits for
uncaught exceptions.
The issue tracker links in
the instructor notes below and
I leave it to you to setup tracking for
exceptions if you want.